Karissa welcome back to the show another
game with the black pieces is another
victory in a completely Wild game and
once again you were dictating the pace
from the beginning of the game with this
modern approach I mean what was up to
that um yeah I kind of just thought I
would switch it up a bit I think a sha
usually has good prep I figured G6
wouldn't be something she's expecting
and I'm having a lot of luck with this
uh suran CED my dark squar Bishop so uh
yeah that was kind of my thought process
behind this choice and it was at this
point when she decided to uh not
continue being a pawn up and just allow
you to take on F4 did this decision by
her surprise you this was also uh the
first the novelty in the
position yeah so I know that F takes E5
is the best move and it kind of goes
into a better end game for uh White
after Knight D7 but I kind of thought it
was unlikely that you would find um all
of this you know like Bishop E4 here and
then there are a couple more precise
moves that wh's needs to sort of keep a
solid Advantage um so I was definitely
surprised by Castle but you know since
it wasn't something I looked at I
assumed it wasn't something very good
and I think I handled it okay because
after I take on F4 all of my pieces on
the king side can get out properly you
were definitely right about that one
because it gave you good position maybe
even a winning position after a few
inaccuracies from your opponent and at
this point this move Knight to D3 was
the final move that more or less gave
you the decisive
Advantage yeah I thought um Bishop A2
was interesting I was definitely a bit
worried after she sacrificed The
Exchange and you know like my light
squares for a while seemed a bit iffy so
I felt I had to play carefully but um
yeah I managed it okay I
think well Karissa congratulations guys
any questions for Champion so far no
it's all going very well for you Karissa
keep up uh the good
work thank you absolutely as uh Karissa